Tổng hạn của ghi gì em nhau ngài mình bố thích ngày bệnh trở bước.
Xeu và Washington đã hoàn tất bản đi nhớ trước kế,
tổng lực có thảo thật đà đồ trong cuộc gặp thực lịch bởi tổng phủ mịch đồ nha Trump.
Hồi thằng trước tại gông dù,
pháp biểu trên truyền thêm,
ông Li nói thảo thật mới trải giọng từ thương mai,
hành ninh, đời ca lĩnh vực công nghệ và khu phòng,
dìm nền lưỡi nhất là việc hành quốc sẽ mắt đầu đẩm tổng ngầm chạc mằng năng lực hạt chân,
một bước phát triển vật bật trong năng lực hạt quan bước xíu,
hành nước tục thống nhất thình thành qua này đổi tất triển lực với đẩm tổng,
chỉ tới nhật tạo và ngành công nghiệp hạt nhân dân xử.
Vì thương mại, ông Li sẽ nhận Mỹ đồng ý giảm thế nhất khẩu của hành hoa hành quốc,
từ hành lắm tần Trump, sống công me lắm tần Trump,
chỉ vụ hành quốc sẽ công bố lộ truyền chỉ đến triển thành trong thời gian tởi,
thật là này đường đầy ra là giống mốt quan trọng,
giống hành quốc sẽ chặt liên mình ăn nền về Mỹ,
trong bối cạnh môi trường của gần ngày càng tăng thằng,
nông thời thuốc này dân nhờ hành quốc tiếp cận thì chúng Mỹ thật là hơn.